boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sockin very
excited to be talking about
neuromodulation enhanced mindfulness we
have dr. Jay sanguinetti joining us on
the show hello hey great to be here
thank you so much for coming on really
appreciate it super excited very
grateful to the week in future summit
that we were both just that as well such
an awesome congregation of psychedelics
meditation technology and you were
speaking there this is awesome and now
we have you on the show really excited
Jays background he is a research
scientist at the University of Arizona
focused on how neural modulation can
augment cognition and mindfulness using
transcranial magnetic electrical
ultrasound and near-infrared light
stimulation he's also the assistant
director for the Center for
consciousness studies which runs the
largest conference on the study of
consciousness and you can find the links
in the bio below to his website Jay
Sanguinetti comm as well as the Twitter
so let's jump into things with one of
our favorite questions to ask Jay what
are your thoughts on the direction of
our world start with a big question well
you know I think that is one of the most
interesting times to be alive as a human
which is a big statement I know and
probably anytime that you're alive as a
human feels like the most interesting
time but there are these two extremes
that are facing us and one of them is
economic and environmental change on a
scale that I don't think humans have
lived through before we are growing
together as a species there's almost 8
billion people on the planet and our
economies are intermixing in this global
economy which is leading to all kinds of
interesting disruption
you know flow of goods and things like
that and at the same time we have this
environmental crisis and I think that
there's enough data there now to start
becoming fearful to start worrying about
the future over the next couple hundred
years and so on one end there's a lot of
reason to be scared
about what it looks like to be
human over the next fifty hundred
hundred and fifty years on the other end
we have all this amazing technology and
technological advancement both on the
end of having magical little boxes in
our pocket that have all the information
humanity seems to have ever created
right there at your fingertips to the
advances in medicine broadly that are
going to drastically extend human life
so I think we're nestled between these
two interesting situations we're on one
end we have a crisis that is solvable
and we still have time to solve it and
on the other end if we can make it past
some of these significant thresholds and
just hold on to the environment long
enough we're gonna see a future unlike
anything that was ever written in the
great sci-fi books in the 1950s I mean
we're gonna see a future we can't even
imagine and so it's super exciting if we
need to if we can just activate
ourselves to solve some of these crises
that are facing us especially the
environmental crisis we're gonna get to
a future that's going to be amazing to
live in and so I'm optimistic about it I
think that human nature is to be curious
and to solve hard problems we've done
that all through our history and so I
think if we can get together
collectively and get over you know our
individual needs and work as a group
global group and I think we're going to
solve these problems and our children's
children are gonna see a future that we
wouldn't even recognize excellence and
this is alright let's go into the
journey now so nach Natchez Mississippi
Natchez Natchez Mississippi is the
birthplace and then how did you get
hooked into science neuroscience when
you were younger and then teach us about
the transition all the way to the
University of Arizona it's a good
question in I really wasn't that much of
an academic kid I struggled all the way
up to high school really I think I was
sort of bored in school and so I was
always interested in things like
astronomy in the south we have the
NASA camp and Alabama you know I did
things like that it sort of got me
interested in science but as a kid I
always thought I was gonna be a
professional soccer player or a
basketball player or maybe a racecar
driver you know I had aspirations that
had nothing to do with science and I
think I probably thought that was kind
of geeky growing up somewhere around my
junior year of high school I realized
that I wasn't gonna get into college
with my grades that I had and so that
kicked my butt into high gear I started
taking what are called AP classes
advanced placement classes in North
Carolina and it was actually in a class
on psychology and neuroscience that
really sort of woke me up woke up my
sort of intellectual curiosity but I
think was always there you know as a kid
it just I never had the right
environment to really bring it out and
it was an AP psychology actually the
professor or the the teacher at the time
who's now a professor said something
that really challenged me as a kid he
said everyone in this room is gonna
become like their parents and he said
this clap by the end of this class
you'll know why I'm saying that and I
was like no way you know you know 16
year old teenager I'm not going to
become like my parents but by the end we
have learned about genetics brain
science the the role of environment on
all of those things and by the end I
read a term paper on it and I said yeah
I'm probably gonna be like my parents
that's okay you know now I think that's
okay and so really through that it just
activated me and that's really what I
wanted to do from that point on yeah
whoa cool I love shifting moments like
that yeah that's great and then how did
from there then you go okay University
of Arizona is where I want to go and do
this PhD how did that transition happen
I got to undergrad degrees one was in
philosophy and it was really focused on
philosophy of science and sort of
consciousness studies generally defined
I learned pretty quickly that there was
a whole nother side to that question
which is what's the brain have to do
with that and so I got a degree in
psychology and neuroscience we had a
psychology program and I worked in the
neuroscience
and I really got to see that question
from both dimensions what is what are
the cells and the networks of cells have
to do with creating consciousness and
one of the questions around that and
then what are the philosophical rational
traditions around consciousness what we
know about consciousness you know things
like cogito ergo zoom you know kagu
darker some things like Descartes said
you know I guess so I kind of learned
about the historical tradition which
really framed the way that I think about
how the brain is involved in
consciousness how consciousness it
evolves from the brain and things like
that so I applied to several
universities for graduate school I
didn't think I was going to get into any
of them so I applied to like 15 schools
and the U of A University of Arizona
was the one that really had both a a
strong philosophy program and a strong
neuroscience program and a strong
psychology program and so I ended up
getting into a few of the schools and
chose the University of Arizona
specifically because it was right at the
center of all these interests that I had
I had also seen a movie called what the
bleep do we know some of your viewers
out there might know that movie at that
point I really liked the movie now I
think it's portraying quantum physics
and consciousness and the totally wrong
and incorrect way but there was a guy in
that movie Stuart Hameroff that I sort
of gravitated to you know even an
undergrad and he was at the University
of Arizona
he runs the Center for consciousness
studies which now in the system director
too and so I think on some subconscious
level I had this wish to kind of work
with him I never actually thought it
would happen but I think uncon you know
there's all this unconscious stuff that
drives your behavior actually and I
think that was one of the things that
kind of drove me there I ended up
meeting Stuart about three years into
graduate school and now I work with him
and he's a good friend so kind of worked
out and what an awesome intersection
philosophy psychology neuroscience yeah
I think therefore I am there's so much
to end up still in the next century this
seems like it's going to be that century
of neuroscience understanding
ah yes it's gonna be very exciting along
with lots of other subjects but let's do
the okay cognition and neural systems
this is what was the focus up until 2014
and you were give us give us the thesis
on the visual on the visual system they
were understanding and working with sure
so my PhD was in a program called
cognition in neural systems and the idea
was really to look at cognition which
means memory perception emotion these
are cognitive constructs that actually
come from Aristotle's philosophy he had
on his library just broken consciousness
into these concepts and so today we
think that they have a real place in the
brain somewhere and we're sort of
looking for them but they're good
organizing constructs for looking at
brain function and so we start with a
question like what is perception how
does perception work what are the
organizing principles for the perceptual
system and you know how the brain takes
all this information from the retina and
figures out what's out there it's
actually a really really difficult
question and when you try to teach a
robot how to do that which is happening
right now all over the country all over
the world it's very hard actually to
teach a robot how to parse the visual
scene and so we start with that question
and then we ask how what does the brain
have to do with that question how is the
brain systems and the neural systems
underneath sort of extracting
information in a way that's relevant for
building perception on top and so it's
the intersection of psychology and
neuroscience is a short way to say that
so when I entered school I really wanted
to study consciousness that was the
question how what is consciousness how
does it emerge from the brain or is it
is it everywhere you know can we can't
even answer that question when I pitched
this early on in graduate school the
answer was you'll never get a job asking
that question most people and the
neurosciences are going to think you're
crazy and you should probably not use
that word when you're at certain
conferences and so the idea was to study
something tractable meaning is there a
question that we can actually get
answers to the question of consciousness
we may never actually have an answer
because we're too stupid to figure it
out for example so pick a question that
we can actually study and define and me
as a small limited individual human
scientists you know a question that I
can advance the field very incrementally
and so the question became how does
memory influence what we see and that's
a sort of fundamental question about how
perception works because leading up to
about the 1980s the idea was that the
visual system completely takes the
visual scene apart so for example if I
show you an object here it has a
definable line but this is actually a
very hard problem for a robot a robot
would have a hard time telling you that
this is a cup because it's clear the
edges are hard to see and it won't be
able to define them but you look at it
and you see there's an edge and there's
an edge and so somewhere in the visual
system there's a little bit of a neuron
there's a little system with neurons
that picks out this little bit this a
little bit this a little bit this a
little bit and it says there's an edge
it feeds it up to the next level in the
brain and that part of the brain takes
all of that and says okay we have a line
and then another part of the brain says
I think that line belongs to this area
right and that's the problem the robot
has the robot may see the line and say
it belongs over here and then it'll say
there's a cup you know cup space way
over here or something and it'll screw
it up
but our brain says there's a line and
there's some object and then it feeds it
up and the other part of the brain says
I think it's a cup and then you can
reach and you can grab it and you can
pick it up and so the question is how
does the brain do that so quickly you
could throw that cup at me with water in
it and you could state the water could
stay in the cup and I could catch it and
I could drink it you know most robots at
this point couldn't do something like
that and so the idea was that over time
over the 30 36 35 years however old I am
I've had all this experience of dealing
with the world and dealing with clear
cups and I figured out that that
situation right there on that table is
probably a clear cup and not a clear
elephant or a clear cap or something
like that and so the brain must be using
memory from higher loved
feeding it back down to the visual
cortex and telling the visual cortex
what to expect in increasing efficiency
increasing yeah excitability efficiency
expectation is one way to think of it
and so the brain is saying there's more
than likely a cup there and not a tiny
clear elephant right and if you see a
tiny clear elephant you've got a problem
probably or you're on a psychedelic
right and so the brain is constantly
priming the rest of the brain past based
on past experience and that was really
what I wanted to study how does that
happen how early in the visual
processing stream does that priming
actually happen and it turns out
ancestrally perhaps for I mean yeah
maybe there's some older memory that's
tuning the system and that's likely
that's probably what genetics is doing
to the brain and so we basically used a
neuroimaging technique a way to look at
brain activation to ask how quickly in
time does memory feed back into the
visual system and we found very very
early whoa basically the visual
hierarchy is feeding back all the way to
the earliest inputs of the visual system
called v1 and v2 as we think and it's
really priming the system at the
earliest level which just sort of went
up against some of the basic models
about the way the visual system works so
so are we could say that our deepest
let's say libraries of memory it has has
a feed back to the earliest parts of the
information coming in through the visual
system yeah and so that that that
feedback mechanism that that's occurring
increases efficiency mm-hmm okay okay
sure increases efficiency updates the
model is a way to think about it the
visual system is constantly creating a
model I mean what I'm looking at right
now in the world is a model of the
visual input I'm not actually looking at
the visual world and that model is based
on past experience and of course you can
tune that model in interesting ways
through the psychedelics brain
stimulation or try not eating for 30
six hours or 72 hours that also will
change the model and you can have some
pretty interesting experiences so you
know the model is constantly being
updated based on incoming information
and old information and it's just
constantly tuning this model based on
you know the best the best possible
guess about what's out there in the
world but you know that was one of the
sort of take-home messages from my
research and from my whole training is
that what I'm looking at is just the
best guess that my brain can give me
it's not really the actual data it's an
interpretation of the data based on past
experience and based on input and it's a
very good guess of course I mean it
lines up pretty well yes yes and then
there are ways to hack into that icon
that we've turned the cup into an icon
and so if we want to get really in a
space of awe about it we can do
potentially things like a psychedelic or
we can do something that resets us to
that childlike state and so there's
different ways to kind of tap into maybe
some of the earlier ways that we were
initially have had aw around a share or
a human or a building or a location
around the world we have an image the
first image your brain sees things you
don't you were just explaining this to
us okay
so walk us through this sure so these
are the stimuli we used in my experiment
and typically these are flashed for
about a hundred milliseconds a tenth of
a second very fast on the screen and
they go off and the typical percept the
perception that the subject has is of a
black novel object so we ask them what
do you see they just say novel and we
also show them things like a tree you
know black tree a black basketball and
they'll say familiar so it's novel
familiar novel familiar novels so here's
a novel stimulus but what we've done
actually is we've embedded a familiar
stimulus on the outside so the border is
actually a seahorse
on both sides and those seahorses are
making the novel object in the middle
and the question was does the brain also
see a seahorse
even though the subject doesn't
consciously see the seahorse and there
are two different theoretical ways did
theories predicted different things
basically one theory said the brain is
gonna assign the object this is called
border assignment and visual
neuroscience the brain says there's a
border and then it says the border
belongs to the black object and then you
consciously see novel object so that's a
feed-forward theory of vision the
feedback theory the one that we believed
in at the time said the brain sees a
border and it considers both situations
it considered maybe there's something
out there that's familiar and then
another part of the brain says no no no
it's novel and the other part says I
think it's a seahorse and then and they
start competing there's competitive
process and exact thing happened when I
first yeah right and if you're tuned to
it maybe you can feel like wait a minute
there's something going on or you meant
that happened here right yeah so
basically the idea is there's an
argument happening in the visual cortex
and a part of the visual system says I'm
80% sure there's a seahorse and it's got
all kinds of things going off seahorse
alarm bells the other part says I'm 99%
sure it's novel and the 99% wins and
that's what pops into your consciousness
and so it was really a demonstration
that the brain is seeing objects that
you're not and that was what led we got
a lot of news publication out of this
and new titles where your brain sees
things if you don't which is true your
brain is seeing a lot that you don't in
hundreds of in in hundreds of
milliseconds yeah this argument is
happening yeah so then we become
consciously aware of what the final
decision yeah well that's that's a very
good question that was one of the
fundamental things I was interested in
is you know I was really interested in
consciousness and how do we study it on
a fine-grained scale it turns out that
you can try to figure out the exact
moment when someone is conscious of a
stimulus that you flash for just a
millisecond or five milliseconds or ten
milliseconds it seems to be somewhere
between 200 and 400 milliseconds so if I
flash this on the screen it's a totally
black room you're conscious of something
in your head what you're thinking of but
then you have this flash of an object
how long does it take from the retinal
impinging on the neurons firing all the
way to your lateral geniculate nucleus
into your visual cortex that takes about
50 to 100 milliseconds probably not
conscious then but then you can see the
information volley up the visual system
volley up into the memory system and at
some point along that line it seems like
consciousness emerges of that visual
object and where does the volley go from
the visual system to what where does it
relate to the memory system wet area is
that it kind of goes from visual system
which is in the back to temporal cortex
into the sort of memory system in the
brain and this is all highly
interconnected system but the question
is when does consciousness emerge and
where and to those questions we don't
quite know just yet but it seems like if
you're really measuring the neural
timing with electrical electrical waves
of recording brain activity seems to be
somewhere around 200 to 400 milliseconds
and what we found interestingly is that
the brain is still processing an object
that you'll never consciously see after
that point in time and so the brains
still holding on to it and the question
is why why is the brain doing that and I
think it's it gets back to this notion
that the brain is giving you a guess it
doesn't really know what's out there and
then like as I said this is a very very
difficult question from the brain what's
out there what are all these objects and
so the brain is going I'm gonna hold on
to this just in case I'm wrong if I get
some more information that actually says
no it's a seahorse and you need to eat
that seahorse if you're you're trying to
eat you know if you're hungry and you're
out searching for things you may come
back and scan again and say okay that's
that's something that I want so both of
the probabilities live and then we
collapse one of the two and then that
becomes the what we're consciously we're
but then somehow the memory system also
retains the second one that we didn't
actually collapse and make the decision
of wow there's a lot of
yeah quantum mechanical similarities
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's it's things
aren't as definite when you look in the
brain I mean we have this definite
percept and we feel like this is reality
I'm looking at it clearly this is a
chair I can feel it but the brain is
saying it's probably a chair you know
yeah which that's very similar to
quantum mechanics in the sense that
there's probabilistic wave fields and
they collapse into an object but really
behind that there's still a
probabilistic field and the brain is
just dealing with probabilities all at
the time 99.999% sure that's chair so I
was making the point that what we are
perceiving as a model and it's a
best-fit model that the brain has given
us it's the best guess at what's out
there if you go back into the philosophy
of science and you ask questions like
can we know the truth the actual truth
stuff behind the stuff you know can we
get at the person behind the curtain if
you think about what I'm saying here
it's it's very similar to what Immanuel
Kant argued that what we are perceiving
is interpretation of the sensory data he
called it the Newman and the phenomena
the Newman a-- is the data coming in the
phenomena is what we're looking at it's
a model being wrapped around the datum
and if that's the case we're always
going to be stuck in the interpretative
model and contactually said space and
time causality and I think 12 total
categories are actually given by our
brains or our minds to the datum so
space and time aren't actually out there
space and timer in our heads and they're
added to the data because that's the
only way we can understand the world we
have to have data spatially and
temporally organized otherwise this
would just be a mess and if that's the
case then what does that say about our
models and science they're models
they're just going to be good models and
we can get keep getting closer and
closer to the truth but we're always
stuck inside the model and that's a
crucial point you know when we're
teaching our students in the lab now we
we try to get that across you know you
don't have to pretend like we're gonna
know everything because we're scientist
you got it you got to understand that
this is a model and it's a it's probably
a better model than astrology for
example if I can pick on astrology for a
minute
you know astronomy versus astrology the
Astronomy model is a much better model
of what's going on out there
astrology is talking about other things
maybe but if it tries to predict the
movement of the stars and things
astronomy is a better model it's never
going to be the complete model of the
cosmos and so we have to sort of
understand that because we're locked in
these perceptual models this would be a
mess if it wasn't temporally and
spatially organized yeah quite in this
quite cool okay and then also that the
MA were limited to the model and we're
gonna all constantly be trying to update
the models to get closer and closer to
the source code of the reality and maybe
we can get to some things of the source
code hopefully and and then also run our
own simulated worlds yeah I think that's
also the power of science is that it's
it's giving us an updated model that
seems to be moving closer no a
philosopher is gonna interject and say
wait a minute isn't the circular right
you're using a model to understand the
model and you're moving forward but by
by testing the model with data and with
feedback from a community of other
scientists there seems to be a way to
move dude maybe I can give Plato's cave
as an analogy and Plato he says that the
situation that we're actually in is
we're tied to a cave there are these
people in this cave they're tied to the
cave and they're looking at shadows the
Sun is illuminating everything and
creating shadows on the wall the people
in the cave think that's reality it's
all they know they see shadows in the
wall but reality is that there's a cave
there's the world out there and that the
shadows are actually being caused by the
Sun and so the nice thing about science
is its we're just creeping out of the
cave very slowly
by taking the empirical data and testing
the model and there's one one one girl
over there in the corner who's saying
you know you guys are looking at that
shadow but or you're looking at reality
but if you if you look at it from this
angle the whole thing changes the math
changes or whatever she's doing right
she's doing something too
challenge that model and I think that's
really the power of Sciences even though
it may never be complete it's somehow
moving closer to getting us a little bit
outside of the cave and it may even one
day say there's the Sun everything's
actually being lumen ating by this this
other source that nobody was looking at
quantum physics or something beyond
quantum physics whatever it is and then
so then how did then the idea come up
that you wanted to do the postdoc with
army research labs your nice labs as
well and and the non-invasive cognitive
enhancement lab okay so walk us through
the movement from doing all this to that
sure so it's back in graduate school in
Tucson at U of A I started doing an
experiment where we were recording from
inside people's brains it's recording
EEG the electrical signal from patients
who are undergoing brain surgery so I'm
scrubbed up I look like you know a
medical doctor I've got the blue garb on
and they're putting electrodes down in
the brain to try to help help
Parkinson's patients sort of deal with
that issue of the motor trimmer we know
the parts of the brain to put an
electrode you turn that electrode on the
tremor goes away and they can open their
hand up and so we had this nice
opportunity to actually go in I
literally they had a hole in their brain
and the hole in their head electrode in
their brain a wire coming out I'm
standing there at the operating table
the patient has to be awake because his
brain surgery and there's a lead going
into my EEG system and I'm recording
their brain and so I started getting
fascinated with this notion of brain
stimulation because I saw how powerful
that technology really can be and you
turn the stimulator on and they're
tremors go away I mean this person's
life has changed and really that's why I
signed up for science I want I want to
understand consciousness and use that
knowledge to change people's lives
that's that's the goal and so this was
the first case where I was out of my
visual perception lab and it sort of in
the operating room and seeing people's
lives
changed and I got sort of obsessed with
brain stimulation at that point now if
you back up a little bit when I was back
in a neuroscience lab I had actually
seen the Dalai Lama give a speech and
the Dalai Lama said basically if
somebody a brain scientist can create a
surgery or something like that to give
him the effects of meditating without
having to meditate he would sign up that
was back when I was an undergraduate I
heard that and so there's a little
nugget he planted it in my head you know
as a as a student who was really like
susceptible to having that happen and so
here I was I was seeing a brain surgery
I was seeing someone's life being
changed and at that time I was
meditating myself and I was sort of
seeing the changes that meditation can
give you and I started thinking wait a
minute the Dalai Lama said brain surgery
giving you the effects of meditation and
so I really started sort of thinking is
there a way to do this is there a way to
do something like this brain surgery but
of course not with the brain surgery
that would modulate the brain and give
someone the effects of meditation or
maybe if that isn't possible help
someone learn how to meditate quicker
which i think is a more realistic goal
it's - the Dalai Lama endorses which the
Dalai Lama endorsed controversially I
think of the people around him didn't
want him to say things like that but it
really sort of woke me up to this
possibility what would that look like
and what would it look like for someone
with Parkinson's to be able to be in
control sure and yeah so there's so much
potential with neuro stimulation and you
got fascinated being there with a Oh
literally a hole in the cranium and then
electrodes in and then you're reading
the EEG feedback to yourself that's what
a cool moment as well to be present
there yeah
patients would cry I cried the first
time I saw it sometimes the new nurses
there would cry I mean you see it and
it's like this is changing someone's
life this is what we all signed up for
this is what we want to do and here's a
very clear situation where you're seeing
that happen for someone so you know it's
sort of changed me it's it sort of
changed the direction that I wanted
and so I started looking for other ways
to modulate the brain at that point
there were these other systems where he
didn't have to drill a hole you could
put electrodes on the head you could use
very strong magnets so if you've got a
magnetic field you've got an electric
field this way right
going back to basic physics class and so
if you put a magnet and the magnetic
field is moving this way you can induce
an electric current in the brain it can
actually cause the brain to fire so I
kind of knew about these technologies
and I started wondering can we use
something like that to accelerate
meditation and mindfulness I started
sort of moving down that path that's
when I met Stuart Hameroff so I was
actually doing one of these surgeries
it's called a deep brain stimulation
surgery on an OCD patient she had
actually flown from a different country
took her very loud trouble to sort of
get to the operating room and she had
OCD which as you know is a very
difficult disorder you have to be awake
during the surgery and so it took eight
hours just to get her down on the table
to get the hole in her head and somebody
and the operating room figured out that
I have good bedside manners and so they
asked me to talk to her the whole time
and so I was going through this whole
surgery and seeing how painful this was
you know if this works for her it was
going to change her life but this was a
very painful process I was leaving the
operating room and really I think
searching for something else
thinking okay this is gonna work for
this person but isn't there a better way
to do this and I literally ran into
Stuart Hameroff in the hall like I
bumped into him and he turned around and
said hey what are you guys doing here
and I said we're gonna go have a beer
that was a really long surgery and
Stuart said oh you're doing deep brain
stimulation there's actually a better
way yeah and he sort of showed up with
this answers right yeah the non-invasive
brains a non-invasive way and this way
it was actually using focused ultrasound
which was a kind of new concept at the
time so instead of using electrical or
magnetic ways to stimulate the brain
which kind of makes sense because the
language of the brain is sort of
electrical gradients this is actually
using the
energy and using that mechanical energy
focusing it into the brain and actually
trying to stimulate the brain and let's
pull up that second asset that we have
and we can start unpacking this with
visuals as well okay so yeah taking an
ultrasound transducer and targeting
stimulation into specific areas how the
hell do you do this so the trouble with
electricity and magnetism is that it's
hard to target it specifically and
deeply so with electricity it just
spreads everywhere path of least
resistance with magnetism it's hard to
get it deep without causing a seizure
and you don't want to cause seizures and
your subjects and your patients the nice
thing about ultrasound is that you can
actually focus the beam through the
skull and if you can do that properly
and I'm not going to not going to hype
this too much it's a very hard problem
to get the ultrasound through the skull
but if you can solve that problem you
can actually focus the beam anywhere in
the brain theoretically and in a couple
studies they've actually focused it down
to the thalamus which is one of the
lightest spots in the brain yeah so I
think on the next slide we might have a
picture of actually focusing it through
the skull so this is another lab this is
not my lab this is when liggins lab at
university of minnesota and we're
looking at the top of the head so
imagine you slice my head and now you're
looking down into my brain
the focus ultrasound is coming through
the side of the head and focusing it
into the thalamus and you can see how
focal that beam is yeah so the red part
is where we think the modulation is
going to actually have it and you can
target in a 3d space yep with ultrasound
because it's somehow goes into like a
conical exactly yeah it's kind of like
an egg shape coming from a single
transducer now what a lab recently did a
different study actually showed that you
can wake a patient up from a coma by
stimulating their thalamus so this is a
person who has I think a traumatic brain
injury
they've
into a coma they put this person in the
MRI they find the thalamus by targeting
different parts of the brain and then
they stimulated in a way that gets the
thalamus back to its normal rhythm
now the thalamocortical rhythm is
thought to be very fundamental to
consciousness expressing throughout the
brain if you want to think about it like
that and so if you can get that rhythm
going you should be able to get
consciousness to kind of jumpstart and
that's exactly what they seem to have
done in this patient it's one patient
they have to replicate it but if that's
true that really shows the power of
something like this you can get deep you
can do things like wake people from a
coma which is something like you see in
the movies right yeah and it's a
relatively simple technique I mean you
have to have an MRI to do it at this
point so it's expensive but getting the
ultrasound through the skull and
focusing is pretty simple technique
actually okay great so this was the big
aha moment for you which was enough of
this drilling holes through brains let's
figure out how to do this without that
and then waking people through comas
there's so much targeted simulation so
where else were you hoping to get
targeting and what were you actually
doing with the army research labs and
nice labs where were you actually
targeting what were you actually yeah
helping solve so in the beginning what
we did is we targeted through the
temporal window so this piece of the
skull on the side of the head is the
thinnest spot they're here and there's
another spot in the back so like I said
it's hard to get ultrasound through the
skull and so we decided to try to target
parts of the brain that we think we can
get ultrasound to and in the beginning
we did a bunch of pilot test and we
stimulated different parts of the brain
we had people consent into this pilot
and it turns out that basically
stimulating the right prefrontal cortex
made people feel better we actually
enhanced mood and so we thought okay
this is pretty cool we have a mood
enhancer we can use that for treatment
for mood disorders depression anxiety
things like that so the first 200
subjects we ran through several studies
and we basically showed that by
stimulating right through the temporal
lobe sorry the temporal window we can
hit the right inferior frontal
Jerris and we can basically make people
feel better then we did that on a group
of depressed patients we reduced
depression over the first day but with a
five-day protocol we actually reduced
anxiety over five days and so it seems
to be like a treatment that we can use
okay a couple couple questions so we got
new slides we have new slides yes so a
couple questions one of the questions is
that there's a a question about is this
through Hertz is this this is a
frequency mm-hmm is this how what is the
frequency what is the amount of power
behind this that's that's a crucial
question if you're asking about safety
now the thing about ultrasound is that
high intensities can destroy tissue you
can heat the tissue up or you can
cavitate you can create bubbles the
bubbles will move and the bubbles will
burst and that causes a sonic wave and
that's actually used to treat things
like kidney stones so that's been well
mapped of course you can use ultrasound
for imaging as well so fetal imaging
brain imaging they actually use
ultrasound to image the brain in the
hospital for stroke and so what's nice
about this field is the whole energy
spectrum has been relatively well mapped
not a hundred percent of course but we
know below a certain wattage so below
about 720 milli watts per centimeter
square it's safe to use on the body on
the fetus on the fetus brain on the
fetus body all the way up to the human
brain and the adult brain and the adult
body if you go above 720 milli Watts up
to a couple watts there's a grey region
we don't really know how safe that is
it's probably safe and as far as I can
tell it's safe we don't have a lot of
empirical data so we don't do that if
you go above many watts you start
heating up the brain or cavitating the
brain so we definitely want to avoid
that and anybody out there who reads
about my research or hears about it who
wants to create a device they have to
understand this you know this is kind of
a fear that I have actually is I'll tell
people you could use ultrasound to
enhance your meditation they try to
build an ultrasound device and instead
of point 1 watt or 0.1 0.1 or 0.05 watts
they use 10 watts or 100 watts that
would hurt a person
we could tell someone actually yeah so
you know that there's a danger range
here that is a little bit different than
using electricity and magnetism and
that's why we have to do this in the lab
we have to do it with scientific
controls and medical controls we have a
hospital that's in walking distance to
my lab I collaborate directly with
medical doctors everything has to be
very controlled and it like you said
within a hundred to seven hundred let's
say milliwatts and you're not it's not
ten watts
right yeah this is a this especially
with the biohacker movement lots of
people are neuro hacking they're really
trying to get into how to hack
themselves and so this is a warning yeah
public service announcement do it yeah
and make sure that if you are that
you're being extremely vigilant with it
yeah with yeah yeah okay
doesn't matter evil always wins and
that's the bottom line you know I'd say
evil wins in the short term and the good
wins in the long term yeah this planet
is littered with lost civilization
thanks for being you so then okay so
then what then that was power and then
what about so powers and milliwatts what
about then a frequency mm-hmm yeah so
there's power there's duty cycle there's
the fundamental frequency so the
ultrasound frequency and then there's
how often you pulse that and actually
for safety all of these interact and so
it's not just power you could actually
potentially do damage at the FDA limit
if you did it continuously for 10 hours
and so it's not just the wattage it's
how often you pulse it how often you're
doing it to that brain how much of a
break you give to the brain and so what
we do on the human skull going through
the skull is usually about half a
megahertz megahertz has a million
oscillations a second and that seems to
be the sweet spot for getting ultrasound
through but doing it as safely as we can
five hundred thousand oscillations right
second so 500 kilohertz or half an
additional 500 a mega thousand
oscillations a second yeah it's a lot
damn that's a lot yeah whoa
okay all right so all these things come
together to the safety okay
critical and also just just barely
starting it into the weeds of the
science it's such a yeah and the
technicals it's very interesting stuff
okay what do we have here this is from
another lab this is from Kim's lab in
South Korea what they're doing is
they're trying to focus the ultrasound
down to the visual cortex oh of course I
like this because this is a visual
stimulation study and the idea is if you
can cause visual cortex activity you
could actually cause someone to see
something that's not there
so a little hallucination that's called
a phosphine and you can actually get a
phosphine if you just press on your
eyeball uh-huh don't press too hard but
I press then you see the little little
lights little flurries they're kind of
fun
that's a phosphine so you're getting
that because you're actually causing the
retinal cells to fire you're actually
pushing on those cells and you're
causing some firing so you can also do
that by pushing on the visual cortex
directly if I drilled a hole in your
head I pushed on it with some
electricity then I would get you to see
things that aren't there so they're
doing that with ultrasound you can see
the little transducer this is actually
being done in the MRI which is pretty
neat and what you see on the screen is
actually the ultrasound causing visual
activation and for I think about 70% of
the subjects although it's been a while
since I've read this 70% of them got the
stimulation and they actually saw little
visual flurries so the little visual
phosphenes that weren't actually there
and that shows it's focal and you can
actually cause brain activation which is
pretty neat and does it requires a
substance that acts as a conducive as
well or yeah in the scanner usually use
water ultrasound passes right through
water use water so there's a big water
bag you lay your head back in the water
bag and the transducers behind the back
okay so that's the best way to do it in
the scanner there's some heating things
you have to worry about in the scanner
so water is the best for that
in the lab we usually use ultrasound gel
so you just use the same gel they use
for fetal imaging you can use that
interestingly there's a paper out of the
UK I think that showed that KY jelly
works better than ultrasound gel for
ultrasound transmission yeah
just for various you know physics
reasons yeah and also KY jelly is
cheaper than ultrasound gel we don't
usually keep that in a lab because it
looks weird and the market the stock
price of KY went up we can get them to
sponsor this episode is sponsored by KY
jelly Lube so what did they what did you
see when you did the when they were
doing this this visual cortex
stimulation here what did the lab see
yeah what was happening when it was
successful the stimulation stimulation
here so basically it caused the subjects
to see that visual percept but what was
really neat is how without oh yeah
without pressing or yeah you just I mean
so the person just sitting in the
scanner the ultrasound is shooting into
their visual cortex and they're just
looking at a blank screen I think or
just looking into the scanner and every
once in a while they get a pulse and
they would just see a flash okay pulse
they'd see a flash and then nothing
flashed for them nothing actually in
front of them yeah and they were
reporting actually where it is because
the visual cortex has a retinotopic map
so there's a map here I can split it
like this right so this quadrant
actually has a spot this quadrant has a
spot and then you can just map the whole
thing and so if you actually move the
ultrasound around I can actually move
the little hallucination around your
visual scene to make a dance yeah and
ultimately what my lab is actually
working on it's trying to actually you
have to be careful about the way you say
this because it's
scary if you say it wrong but you could
create a holographic ultrasound image in
the skull so you could create like a
ball or a square for example you could
hit that into the visual cortex with
ultrasound beam and then I would see a
little ball correct right and then I
could see a little ball over here so
basically this is already happening
right now potentially we're working on
it yeah yeah we want to demonstrate the
idea - yeah - do altra sound stimulation
be able to see yeah things that are not
actually physically there but they're
stimulated in this could already be
happening what you're describing of
being able to stimulate things into the
physical world could already be what we
are
in fact experiencing right now right
yeah so easy to hypothesize if you're
already talking about it like this okay
all right and then the next slide is
well with this all right so this is a
model that we've created in our lab so
it's kind of hard to see on the screen
but there's a brain there's some brain
tissue underneath and this is an actual
person skull and as I was describing the
real trick is trying to get the
ultrasound through the skull as a focus
beam the skull has different sort of
thickness around different parts of it
has little deviations and aberrations
and as you push the ultrasound beam
through the skull it bends it or
reflects it absorbs it there's all kinds
of things that are not good for trying
to get it through the skull and so part
of what our lab is doing is trying to
find novel ways to focus that beam and
do what's called aberration correction
correct the beam as it's going through
and if we can do that the best way would
actually create this crazy sci-fi helmet
where you had tens of thousands of
little ultrasound elements and all of
them are shooting down into the brain at
once that's the best way to do it
ultrasound 10,000 little ultra yeah I
put a million if I could a million of
them and then there's a billionaire
watching who wants to give me a lot of
money and then I'll make this device
yeah and then you can like hyper target
with Riley and ultrasound rather than
just one yeah yeah okay
then interesting but that would also it
would still have to go from the skull in
so you I mean it would still be
partially stimulating all the regions on
the way in right so it still partially
stimulates on the way in does it right
it depends on how much energy each say
say that the non target regions so yeah
the ultrasounds going through all of
that but if you had enough tiny elements
each one of those could admit you know
say 50 milli watts
everybody's sending 50 milli watts which
shouldn't affect the brain all that much
as far as we can tell so 50 milli watts
is coming down and then it sums to 700
million got it
that would kind of be the idea okay and
then the non target areas aren't even
being yeah they're getting a little
energy a little jiggle but then they
just say okay I'm going back to normal
okay cool cool the other neat thing
about that is you need to be able to
image at the same time so the brain is
moving if you just slosh around your
brain moves around a little bit every
heartbeat actually moves the brain so
you need a real-time measure of where
the brain is and where the sensor is the
electrode or the ultrasound transducer
in real-time
now of course ultrasound can image we
know all about that because that you do
fetal imaging and so you could actually
image with ultrasound you could actually
look at brain activation with ultrasound
looking at the bowl or the blood
activation and you could stimulate all
at the same time so this is my like
Ferrari you know dream car of a brain
stimulation helmet I mean this is really
where you could go and actually a couple
labs and France have shown recently that
in animals if if you take the skull off
which they do in animal labs which makes
me feel bad for the animals but take the
skull off you can actually get real-time
fine-grain images of the brain beautiful
images if people look them up they'll
see them actually better resolution than
an fMRI so the structure you can see all
this beautiful structure and then if the
animal is doing a task you can see the
brain activation with ultrasound so
that's my dream have that for humans but
leave the skull oh yeah
basically okay so you can get real so
you're trying to get you're trying to
get the neural activity real-time being
mapped as you do a neuro modulation
yeah and then constantly be able to see
what's happening moment a moment right
and that would allow us to solve this
problem the aberration correction
problem because then we'd be able to see
what we're doing while we're doing it
and then we can correct yes yes yeah
okay and let's go to that next image
wrong
okay and what was this skill the decibel
skill and what's this scale same scale
oh this is missing so this is a wattage
scale so this is a water total watts the
other one was decibels you can you can
look at the total amount of sound energy
you're putting in in decibels or you can
convert that to wattage oh those
different ways to look at the vision and
is this in Watson not Miller what this
is an overall watt so there's a little
subtlety here there's two ways to
measure wattage really there's more ways
to measure it in the brain you can
measure it over space you can measure it
over time or over space and time wool
and like I said we think in space time
so we need to really think about both
dimensions and really if you think about
it over space I could just ask how much
total wattage is there here but if
that's all I reported as a scientist it
would be a little bit of trickery
because really I want to know how much
wattage is that neuron right there
getting right because you really want to
be careful about the overall neural
overall wattage for very small spaces
and then you could ask how much is it
getting over time which is another
question
so the overall wattage that the FDA
limits to the body and the brain is in
actually over a hundred watts total mm
but you could say that's 100 watts over
10 years right I mean how much time
right yeah so if you take the time into
account the FDA says per centimeter
square of tissue or bone or brain over
time you're limited to 720 milli watts
so I could put another scale or how long
so that that's also that's taking time
into
so time goes into the equation
automatically okay over oh so 720
milliwatts per cubic centimeter
centimeter of tissue yeah / / / total
stimulation for the total simulation
time so that's one thing that they
haven't regulated yet which they will at
some point is how much so I could burst
within a microsecond you know a tenth of
a millisecond to a millionth of a
million and in that burst I could
deliver all 720 milli watts does the
brain does that damage the brain we
don't actually know and so that's what I
was saying there are these subtleties in
the science that we haven't mapped yet
and someone who doesn't understand the
subtleties may say oh I can do all seven
20 milli watts within one microsecond
and then they get vascular damage or
microhemorrhages and their brain right I
mean student stuff like that could
happen yes yes so right now we follow
protocols that come out of the animal
literature that we know are safe because
they cut up the brains of the animal and
they look at it from different
dimensions okay and then here's some of
the data the figures of data mm-hmm yes
teach us about that if you go back to
the other side real quick okay so one
question we started asking is can we
modulate parts of the brain that are
really starting to show up from the
mindfulness literature really what we're
interested now is accelerating
mindfulness practice and so here looking
from the top down we're ultrasounding
into the anterior cingulate cortex it's
a very important part of the brain for
error monitoring so if I gave you a task
and I said every time I use the word V
put your hand up and every once in a
while I'd say three and you put your
hand up that's an error that part of the
brain would send the signal to other
parts of the brain to make the brain
ready for the error I'm so the motor
system has to get ready the social
system has to say oh I'm so stupid you
know I know I got it
act smarter you know there's all these
systems that deal with the error so that
seems to be emerging from the anterior
cingulate okay now that's really
important for mindfulness because what's
happening in mindfulness
seyed are supposed to focus on the
breath your object is the breath feel
the breath out of your nose doing it
over and over every once in a while I'm
gonna start thinking about something
else that's essentially an error mmm and
now you have to go up bring the
attention back to the breath yes bring
the attention back so that's a really
important part of mindfulness we think
that the ACC the interior cingulate is
involved in that process and so the idea
was if we put a little ultrasound energy
into the ACC
can we make someone more mindful or can
they learn mindfulness faster excellent
okay yeah yeah this yes so that is a
similar thing with the when the font
comes on the screen and it says the word
read but it's written in blue yes stuff
like that and then your brain is like ah
okay now I know to not make that mistake
and then the social like you said that
the same thing with meditation when
you're following your breath and then
everyone experiences this something but
I'd say you go to your calendar or your
email or your yeah social life and and
then so the the the the ACC seems to
play a pretty serious role in the body's
ability to reclaim the attention and
bring it back at least monitor at least
Maude's the monitoring piece and then a
signaling piece and then if you make
another mistake you know it's that sort
of monitoring within monitoring that's
going on it's involved in a lot of other
things as well just your sort of
cognitive control or regulation in
general the list is crazy yeah yeah yeah
of what there's an abundance of spindle
cells which is a completely different
shape neuron than normal there's like
there's crazy stuff there yeah but let's
yeah let's stick on on on the effect on
neural modulation with it the ACC and
then how that effects mindfulness yeah
sure so basically we brought subjects
into the lab this location was a control
site for our mood studies because we
were claiming stimulating here made
people feel better but what if it's just
stimulating anywhere in the brain maybe
the default mode is stimulate with
ultrasound you feel better so we
targeted at the top of the
and that was going right down into the
interior cingulate and we claim that
that shouldn't do much to mood in the
way that the right stimulation was doing
so in the end of the study well pre and
post before and after the study we gave
a mindfulness scale which is just a
scale that asked you know how much are
you paying attention currently how much
are you thinking about the past how much
are you thinking about the future it's
not a great scale but it tries to get at
this notion of current attention in the
moment yeah so we just gave this to
people these people are not meditators
none of them had meditation experience
they weren't meditating during the study
they were just sitting there doing
nothing and we just gave him the scale
just to see what would happen and the
idea was maybe stimulating the ACC would
give them some attentional control so
they would be more mindful more in the
moment more likely to engage currently
with what was going on instead of sort
of talking to themselves and that kind
of stuff and then so then the this of
the neuromodulation that you performed
with ultrasound was to the ECC for how
many milliwatts over how long how many
sessions they got 30 seconds so we what
we're trying to do is the smallest dose
possible to get an effect effect okay
it's called the olara principle in
medicine you just use as little possible
to get the effect effect yeah so 30
seconds seems like way too little for us
but we were actually getting it there so
we tried 30 seconds for how many people
and that study there was over 30 they 35
or something like that and then the next
asset is what you had as yeah okay cool
so this is the data from the mindfulness
scale and essentially moving up the
scale means you're more mindful your
attention is more in the moment on the
left
it's the pre versus post for people who
got ultrasound so basically in the
orange bar there are people who got real
ultrasound to the ACC reported more
mindfulness on the scale we also did
placebo of course in the placebo
condition they moved down slightly it's
not a significant difference but really
there was no difference in mindfulness
which is what
expect and so it seems like just
stimulating that region alone led to
people having more reported mindfulness
in the current moment so pretty neat
yeah yeah okay and then there this is
just the beginning of being able to
apply a neuromodulation for enhanced
yeah mindfulness yeah so this was a tiny
little hint I mean we we didn't really
make much of this this was just a hint
that maybe we could modulate those brain
regions that show up in the mindfulness
literature and actually help people
learn mindfulness quicker and you have
an illustration here the next asset that
kind of breaks down mindfulness a little
bit more yeah yeah so in the lab we're
always doing what we call
operationalizing things that means you
need to define it in a way where you can
empirically study it and mindfulness is
notoriously hard to define what is
mindfulness what is meditation what are
these higher states you know what is
enlightenment I mean I don't think we'll
ever have a definition for something
like that if it's real but even coming
down to mindfulness and just defining it
so we can measure it is very difficult
so I've been working with a meditation
teacher Shinzon Jung a very well-known
mindfulness teacher a brilliant person
someone who really does have a beautiful
mind every time you you're hanging with
him you just learn something new and he
blows your mind Shenzhen has a very
scientific and objective reductionist
way of sort of thinking about
mindfulness so he's a great person for
someone like me to team up with because
you know he's already thought about how
do you operationalize mindfulness how do
you define it how would you study it and
so Shenzhen and I had been working
together for almost two years now I
think when trying to figure out how do
you define mindfulness how do you
measure it and how do you modulate the
brain to help people learn mindfulness
faster that's really what we've been
looking about and really to be honest
Shenzhen's the reason I've gone down
this path I mean who are really sort of
changing my years of experience yeah you
don't have to spend a couple minutes
with him to have your life change mine
so that's how brilliant in band and sort
of convincing he is
and so sensory clarity concentration
power equanimity yes so Shenzhen has
broken mindfulness down into three core
attention skills and he really talks
about it in terms of acquiring these
skills equanimity basically means having
a balanced mind so being able to allow
sensations thoughts and emotions to
arise and fall rise and fall without
sort of resisting them without getting
attached to them without sort of holding
on to them so if you've ever had an an
emotional moment where you need to let
go because you need to have an interview
with someone and you got to stop
thinking about it the more equanimity
you have the more you can just let it go
and pay attention so that's a skill
sensory clarity and concentration power
are skills of concentration so sensory
clarity is being able to track visually
auditorily sense orally sort of what's
happening as a vision scientist I really
like this one because I can measure that
I can give you a bunch of visual stimuli
really fast on the screen and I can ask
how much do you see and someone who
meditates a lot so Shenzhen for example
if you give him a visual paradigm he can
track all these visual stimuli really
fast and so that's a trainable skill
damn versus actually having me be like a
little bit more of like a clouded yeah
yeah right view not even knowing that
you know I can show you two stimuli
really fast you may have just seen them
together as one whereas someone who's
trained their attention would say oh
it's a bird and a plane he's not a very
plane like you saw
concentration power is just being able
to focus on what you're trying to focus
on yeah so that's a really important one
for the modern world because our
attentions being split across everything
everything you know Facebook and Twitter
and our phone and vibration you know the
phone is going off and so our attentions
really being split and where perhaps
nobody knows yet but we might be
actually losing our ability to focus
what we're trying to focus on agreed and
we find in many ways the most meaning in
our lives from sustained periods of
focus on things that are our North Star
yeah that's great yeah I mean one of the
central claims of some forms of Buddhism
is that actually having concentration
power leads to insight insight about the
nature of the self the nature of the way
things work you know these deep insights
that like kind of change the way you see
the whole world so that's called Insight
Meditation and the idea is that you get
things like insight when all of these
things are working together so
Shenzhen's claim really is any one of
those is a good skill to have if you're
a basketball player for example Steph
Curry's probably got all of these really
but you know if Steph Curry really
focused on concentration power he's
gonna make more free throws right so
there's sort of practice level practical
effects from these things but the claim
from shenzhen is that as these things
are working together
that's what mindful awareness is mmm-hmm
having them all together in unison gives
you the ability to get out of your way
to get out of your own emotional turmoil
or whatever's going on yeah and just pay
attention to the present moment and then
as you do that over and over throughout
your life what tends to happen is you
become happier you know you start
finding more meaning out of everyday
life you start tasting your food hearing
your music enjoying hanging out with the
people that you know previously we're
sort of making you upset or annoying you
or whatever so really it's sort of just
by using these skills your general sense
of well-being begins to change and
that's really the good stuff at Shenzhen
talks about it yeah the mindful were in
a combination of these three things can
just radically change our lives our
family community civilizations live so
to be able to do something like a
neuromodulation to hack the processes at
the top of the list because then we can
potentially update the code of our world
in a more
in a way that drives us closer towards
that prosperity right and that's kind of
where were you know where we're heading
with the new Semih sonification
sonication enhanced mindful awareness
okay and the image on the way there this
is an image of the default mode Network
the next one Ronnie right is that what
this one is that's right okay so part of
the question is if if Shenzhen is right
or at least in the right direction of
what mindfulness is can we stimulate
different parts of the brain and help
people have a little more equanimity or
stimulate a part of the visual system
and give you more concentration power so
that when you try to learn mindfulness
you can sort of do that faster you can
learn the practice faster you can see
what is it like for me to actually have
equanimity yeah and now that I have
equanimity what's it like to try to
concentrate on something oh wow
holy cow now I'm not getting distracted
by thinking about you know Donald Trump
messing up the world oh my gosh you know
that's okay
let that go for a minute bring my
attention back you know once once people
sort of feel that you know in their
experience then they can get motivated
to do it more or they can actually learn
you know how to do that quicker and so
the question is if that's possible what
are the brain regions that we target and
that's where things like the default
mode come in so on the left this is a
picture of what happens when you put
someone in an MRI and you just don't
give them a task so you just set them in
there they're maybe waiting for the task
or whatever if you look at what's going
on in their brain you typically see the
same pattern in different subjects
that's called the default mode pattern
and it was called that because it was
thought that's the default mode the
person is usually closing their eyes or
laying in the scanner it's very loud and
when they're in there they're in their
head they're thinking about something
right usually what am I gonna do after
this I got homework I said that stupid
thing to my girlfriend oh my gosh I'm
sort of usually going that negative loop
so that's the default mode
is the rumination ruminations part of it
but it's really about self referential
thing self referential think those
selfing is felt in that you can suck it
up yes selfing has a lot of dimensions
right it's planning its thinking its
thinking negative thinking positive
there's all these different dimensions
to selfing but this core pattern so the
posterior cingulate the medial
prefrontal cortex and some parts of the
parietal lobe that shows up when most
people are selfing it doesn't matter
what culture and what your
socio-economic statuses past experience
whatever it is that shows up and so some
people are claiming this is the neural
physiological basis of the self mm-hmm
that's probably not true I mean there we
may never know what that is but at least
it has something to do with thinking
about the self referring to the self and
that kind of stuff so what happens is if
you have a depressed person in the
scanner you'll see more read more read
means more activation and we're self
referential team more selfing right and
it's usually negative selfie so in
depression you ruminate you get stuck in
negative thought loops I'm so stupid why
did I say that Alan asked me this
question and I really should have
explained it differently that's a normal
process and that's a good process to
have but if I do that for the next five
weeks yeah while I'm giving a talk or a
while and with my girlfriend that's a
problem because then it's taking me out
of what I need to be paying attention to
it that happens in depression and so
you'll see way more red in the blue here
this is long-term meditation and blue
means less activation relative to
control people and so the blue brain is
the the mindfulness brain is actually
the opposite that you see to like the
depression for example that makes total
sense because mindfulness is all about
putting your attention into whatever's
going on if you start selfing you pay
attention to it but then you don't
engage with it right and then you bring
your attention back to Alan and then I
bring my attention to the sound okay
when I sit down in a chair and I don't
have my laptop I don't have TV I don't
have my phone
I don't have anything to distract me
better you sit down in a chair whether
I'm outside or inside wherever if
there's a lot of people walking a lot of
buses or whatever versus if I'm just
looking at some trees without anyone
else there or if I'm just in the studio
space with no one else here what is the
difference between me having a mindful
presence in the chair versus me having a
selfing default mode Network it's a
great question if you figured that out
you'd get a really good science paper
but we have some clues okay and the
clues are so you can think about it as
mind wandering versus mindfulness if you
want to put it on a spectrum okay and
there's ways to study and probe mind
wandering a mind wandering is just
letting your mind do whatever it wants
sometimes it'll pay attention to the
sound sometimes it'll think about what
to eat later sometimes it'll think about
stupid stuff I said it's just kind of
bouncing all around mindfulness is
effort fully focusing on an object
that's one way to do it so but if then
the mind wanders to a place I can that
is not at a place of excessive
rumination like we were saying earlier
but if it wanders somewhere cool like
I'm seeing the plant in a new way sure
if I can I be mindful with that thought
that came up mmm is that that idea so
yeah there's another mindfulness
practice that's not effortfully focusing
its effort for paying attention to
whatever the mind is doing so it's
almost like a third perspective if you
zoom out from it it's called
metacognition in psychology so that's
called open awareness practice you can
do open awareness where if I just try to
start paying attention to the whole room
it almost feels like my consciousness
expands around the room so that's also
mindfulness because you're paying
attention to whatever's going on and you
can let your mind wonder it's fine to do
that but by paying attention to what the
mind is doing it's less likely to get
looped it's stuck in those loops
okay so then there's a base there so the
sides are our mind wandering and mine
fullness and mindfulness could be in a
way a meta perspective on the mind
wandering sure okay I can do that
whereas money intentionally with
potential towards unity with this or a
development of an idea that one is
having yeah yeah and not the excessive
rumination so doing it intentionally
yeah the intention is really important
and the intention from a brain point of
view gets into things like the anterior
cingulate because if you you know this
is a not the right way to talk about the
brain but if you tell the anterior
cingulate another part of the brain says
hey start paying more attention the ACC
is gonna get a little bit more resources
and give you more ability to start
tracking what's going on and if the ACC
is saying well tell me when the
attention tell me when you lose the
ability to pay attention to what's going
on so that's the open awareness piece if
you just start getting lost you start
thinking about food you think about
where your food comes from you think I
want India Indian food you start
thinking I should go to India because I
need to learn how to meditate you know
you're getting lost this is a Sharon
Salzberg analogy that I really like and
Sharon actually went to India to learn
mindfulness to learn meditation and then
turned it into mindfulness in the West
and so you can get lost down that track
that's not mindfulness mindfulness would
be paying attention seeing that happen
and seeing it lead to the next thought
and then bringing your attention back to
whatever's going on and then hearing the
birds and then feeling the sensation how
hearing the bird sounds nice actually
and then saying okay come back you know
and just continuously bringing yourself
back this is an award-winning science
paper this discussion is fascinating
okay
and Morpher and part two at some point
to unpack more did more depth into this
yeah yeah yeah correct so and then this
is the most recent endeavor so this is
now you're doing this at the Center for
consciousness studies at the University
of Arizona but sonication enhanced
mindfulness aware so this is kind of
where we built up to you are now going
to be doing this with most of your time
was conducting this research of
ultrasound neuromodulation to areas like
the anterior cingulate to catalyze
mindfulness right okay yep and what we
did in the beginning is Shenzhen and I
started talking about the feasibility of
this what what would the science look
like how would we know we have a good
effect and a little bit of worrying I
don't see Shenzhen very much because
he's such a mindful person but if your
worries about one thing it's about what
if we do something bad what if we
disrupt sleep or disrupt someone's
ability to make new memories I mean we
are talking about the brain we're
talking about modulating something that
we have very little knowledge about how
it is really works and so we talked
about all this for a year in Shenzhen
and I talked a lot about this and we
decided okay this is worth doing because
if it's real
we'll have clinical interventions for
almost every disorder if you can reduce
suffering at its cause you should be
able to reduce suffering in chronic pain
addiction all the way down the list you
should be able to create an intervention
for all of these things and we thought
that the risk was worth trying but we
wanted to do it on people in the
beginning who have a lot of experience
exploring their consciousness if you
want to think about it like that
so people who know what altered states
are like and they have the skills to
deal with being altered people with a
lot of mindfulness experience have that
skill and so we decided all right the
first subjects will be very long-term
meditators who have enough experience in
practice to be ok if we sort of push
them in a weird direction for a couple
minutes they can bring themselves back
turns out Shenzhen signed up for to be
the first study the first subject the
first study it was going to be Shenzhen
he consented into the study and he was
so overjoyed to be part of this I mean
just being around Shenzhen at this point
wasn't would make anybody happy he's
just so happy so we put Shenzhen through
a two-week protocol and we started sonic
hating the default mode and other parts
of the brain that we
should basically enhance equanimity
you're now not just sonic ating from to
the interior singular doing other areas
yeah okay which ones are you doing so we
did the head of the caudate nucleus
which is part of the basal ganglia wow
that's a deep structure deep strokes an
important structure for basic motor
function all the way to learning and
memory and sleep and other things and so
that's a that's a high risk actually
area but we did that because Shinzon
found this very very fascinating
disorder called eighth i'm Horomia yeah
yeah yeah I talked about that and a TED
talk recently locked in the present
moment right
these people have bilateral lesions of
their basal ganglia and what happens is
if you get the right lesions at the
right place these people go into what
seems like a pseudo are hot if you're a
Buddhist or if you're interested in
philosophy they're completely conscious
without any content like imagine just
being completely conscious of everything
but no contents within that
consciousness everything is just
conscious maybe interesting right able
to tap into a now yeah so in Buddhism
pseudo our hat means someone who's fully
awakened fully enlightened however you
want to define that but they can turn it
on and off yeah yeah and in some
traditions you turn it off to become a
bodhisattva so you can come back and
give give love and and and the the
practice back to the people yes so which
is what the Buddha did so Shenzhen
looked at this and thought aha now we
have a spot in the brain we can target
that if we could safely target just for
a couple minutes or a couple seconds
give someone a taste of that whatever it
is that would radically change someone's
life or if not it would at least help
them zoom into a meditation practice but
the real goal was radically changed
someone get them out of their ego ik
turmoil
long enough to see that this is a
beautiful existence we're all together
we're all one and if we see that maybe
we'll work together to save the planet
and do all the other things that we need
to do so we went after the head of the
caudate we went after the default mode
Network we went after a couple of other
structures in Shenzhen and we gave this
one in a million I think I gave it
Shenzhen was giving it one in 10,000
something like that we just thought this
will be fun
Shenzhen and I will try this and then
we'll go home and laugh about it and
that's it
the first experiment Shenzhen basically
said I think I have more equanimity we
did it again
three days later he's like there's more
equanimity we did a three days later
again he's like this is working holy
crap a lot of expletives came out and
there's so many milliwatts for you at
that point it was 400 milli watts
so I actually haft the legal limit just
to make sure we were being say 30
seconds at this point it was I don't
know the total it was 60 pulses so the
pulses are very short they're micro
pulses they're probably not even 30
seconds total and an HA for different
regions and just to ACC and just we did
just the Basel game just basically wow
the beginning yeah just because I didn't
want to do too much you know we just we
don't we don't want to undo the networks
in the brain over time in editions and
has a relatively old brain he's 73 I
think at this point every three days
you're doing this for for an hour total
so it's 60 pulses over an hour over an
hour okay the pulses are very short we
turn it off just to make sure
everything's okay and turn it back on
now Shenzhen's meditating the whole yeah
hold on yeah so what he's doing is he's
really introspecting he's watching The
Watcher you know he's watching what's
going on he's using different meditative
practices and we give him a little burst
a little jiggle by the second week he
was like I think we're on to something
you should think about doing this more
often and I thought well I'm not gonna
give up my whole career you know for
this kind of crazy meditation person who
shows up in my life and tells me to do
this really sort of interesting thing
but you know okay let's try the trial
again so we waited several months just
to make
sure everything was okay I did cognitive
testing on him we had actually taken MRI
on him a couple times everything seems
fine so then we did a multi-week study
over three weeks this time just based it
out over three days by the third week
shenzhen started really deeply
experiencing those insights that I was
talking about this was really doing
something to him that was opening up the
meditation practice when the pieces came
together equanimity sensory clarity
concentration power right which he
already has a lot of but you know
meditation practitioners you know we we
have our habitual patterns that get
locked in and by stimulating a different
part of the brain different parts of the
brain for Shenzhen it sort of opened up
a new door or something for him and now
you're going to be doing this more with
experienced meditators right okay so
with Shenzhen we thought okay this is
interesting but I'm still not gonna give
up my whole life path Shenzhen is very
biased I'm very biased because I'm a
meditator we want this to work and so we
thought okay we can't even really tell
anybody about this because it's just
Shenzhen so then we replicated this on
five people in the lab we came and they
did four days of the intervention and
there was a control I did a placebo on
him so I knew they were getting placebo
but they didn't see it's single blinded
yeah when they got the real stimulation
almost all of them said way more
equanimity now these are all students of
Shenzhen's mostly at least so they know
the language they know the lingo but
they're also biased again by being
students of Shenzhen and they all said
holy crap way more equanimity like like
being on a retreat like wow you know
days and days of unplugging and focusing
four hours a day but this was just one
hour one hour
and a couple of them were very skeptical
they were like this is silly you guys
the shenzhen little pet project J you
know doing this and whatever but
mindfulness works meditation works why
do we need brain stimulation we
converted most of them at the end they
all said ok this is something that could
potentially change the world keep doing
it ok great and now this is gonna be
rolling out hopefully more now trials
for you at University of Arizona right
gonna be so right we continued
replicating and more people kept getting
a similar effect it doesn't work in
everyone it's not it's not going to just
be a hundred percent effect but we got
enough there that we thought we got to
do this you know we got to do this
full-time because if this is real this
is going to apply to all the different
disorders clinical applications that we
want to apply it to and if that works
it's going to apply to everybody else as
well there's suffering throughout life
for everybody not just people who have
depression or a chronic pain we all have
that and if we can give people the
ability to learn mindfulness skills
quicker that's going to apply to that
suffering and it's going to help reduce
suffering globally global scale I mean
that's the way we're thinking we're
thinking across the globe this is an
intervention that could where yes yes
and there's still so much to understand
about where to induce neuromodulation in
order to amplify mindfulness yeah this
is such a right we have the big we have
the big goal and we know what we want
now we have to validate it so now we're
doing double blinded studies I won't be
with the one doing the the stimulation I
need to be removed at this point so I'll
train people we'll be doing it in the
MRI scanner because you can do them
simultaneously so that way we can see
that we're targeting and activating what
we think we're activating yes and also
look at the brain over time to make sure
we're not increasing this node and
decreasing another node because the
brain is this hugely dynamic system and
we need to make sure that we're not
giving you equanimity power at the
expense of language production right or
learning or something you know
those lines and so we'll be looking at
all of those different dimensions to
make sure that this is a possibility
excellent yeah that complex dynamic that
you just said there a good luck
measuring that right yeah that's very
very difficult I'm basically partnering
with people who are smarter than me and
further along their path yeah and
basically finding people who have
already solved some of these problems
teaming up with them convincing them
this is a worthwhile goal yes and then
using their tools yes and I think at
this point in science in general it's
got to be collaborative when you're
talking about something like this with
you know Buddhist concepts turning into
reductionist mindfulness and then
talking about the brain it's got to be a
collaboration to do something like that
I would love to see this process blow up
and have more and more people that are
going through this at the lab and and
then leaving with transformative results
it sounds like a beautiful yaffle thing
right yeah but even as you say that you
know thinking if you're transforming
someone you have to support that person
and there's a supportive process part of
you know part of what we hope for is
transformation part of what we worry
about is transformation right it's this
sort of two-sided coin because we want
to make sure that person transforms into
a happier person you know finding that
broadly and deeply not just a state of
happiness but happiness as a more
meaningful life really is what we're
going after
yeah so this is a this is a long process
everyone who comes through the lab we're
gonna be following for years that's
giving them support making sure
everything is okay like a
psychotherapist right yeah yeah yeah so
it's a long process yes yes and this the
Center for consciousness studies mm-hm
yeah what is that what are you guys
doing there so it is a Center at the
University of Arizona that was founded
back in the early 90s
by Stuart Hameroff
a couple professors at the University al
kaznia
and a couple others to attempt to define
the problem space for consciousness
studies because before that point you
know in the 80s 70s 60s 50s you couldn't
even say the word consciousness in a lab
I mean if you were alive in the 50s BF
Skinner was reigning the behaviorist you
know they were saying consciousness
isn't really real some of them were I
don't know exactly BF Skinner was but
some of the behaviorists were and they
were claiming that cognition and
consciousness no point in studying it
just study behavior behavioral responses
conditioning fear responses that's all
there is all this other stuff is a
delusion it's a lie you know the
Buddhists also say that this is all a
delusion it's alive but you know from
there through the Chomsky Revolution
through the cognitive revolution it
became okay to talk about cognition
memory perception all these other things
and actually look for them in the brain
as I got my PhD in and so the Center for
consciousness studies was right at the
the beginning of being able to talk
about a science of consciousness what
does that look like what are the
dimensions of that what's the science
what are what's not the science you know
how do you define the barriers in the
boundaries they then hired David
Chalmers who was at the University of
Arizona he's a very famous philosopher
who's basically at the conference back
in the early 90s defined the what he
called the hard problem which is that
you can study the neural correlates of
consciousness what's going on in the
brain as I'm conscious all day but it
doesn't tell you how that creates
consciousness that bridge is the hard
problem so that was kind of the center
in the beginning they spun out
consciousness conference which is now
the biggest consciousness conference in
the world every other year it's in
Tucson and then we do it international
so this year it's an Interlaken
Switzerland and I just learned that I'll
be going this year
axe is gonna help me go yeah really cool
so I'm very very excited about that and
the idea is basically open the doors to
anybody who has something meaningful to
say about consciousness studies now the
trick is we don't have any idea about
what generating consciousness I think
has something to do with the brain
because I'm studied in brain science and
I think things can be reduced until you
find the bits that create consciousness
and it emerges but also I kind of feel
like everything is conscious I'm also
sort of a pansy like yes yeah right and
there's this other bit of me you know
the experiencial bit of me through some
experiences I've had that make me think
like you know the bhagavad-gita the
Hindus were right everything is imbued
with consciousness so I myself hold
contradictory views yes yes and I have
no way to test those as a scientist and
so the consciousness conference has been
very open to letting everybody come
together biologists chemists physicists
all the way to medical doctors and very
well-known people like Deepak Chopra and
we just open the doors
and when we say everyone come together
try to put your ego aside for a minute
try to put some of your bias aside for a
minute and talk about this problem and
let's see if that's fruitful yes and it
seems to have been helpful we haven't
solved the problem of consciousness it's
hard to know how much we've advanced the
field but it's at least given people now
that the modern parlance is a safe space
although that term is kind of funny to
say but it's given a safe space to talk
about conscious in the studies now we've
taken a pretty big hit recently from
academics because we let in all kinds of
weirdness you know weird people if you
want to say it sometimes weird stuff
weird idaite I do on the right track
sometimes right nine Stein's ideas were
we
right I'm pretty quiche and so we're
open to weird ideas you know and letting
that in and and trying to trust the
rational discourse to decide what is
right and really we're trying to create
that context to make sure that it's
moving in the rational discourse sense
great great and the Center for
consciousness studies is what month is
that going to be in Switzerland it's
next month next Switzerland okay
excellent and then and there's online
materials for people to be able to check
out - yeah you can check it out we just
posted for next year we're having it
back in Tucson I think it's in June
again next year
you choose how we have it at this
beautiful resort called those of attend
your resort I don't make any money for
them and that's I'm not giving a
shout-out to them because I'm biased uh
but it's just beautiful resort 400 rooms
we sell out the whole thing there's
about five hundred six hundred people
who come and what's the URL that's a
good question let's search for a Center
for conscious we will study well we'll
make sure that that URL is in the bio
everyone okay quick question on the way
out are we in a simulation my intuition
is yes we're at least in a model and I
can tell you that with high probability
I can't tell you for sure because I'm a
scientist but we are looking at a model
we're interacting with a model all the
time and if you want to call that a
simulation I think it is now if the
simulation has been created by something
higher than us I can't tell you but it
would be cool if that was the case and
then what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing in the world I am a
practicing mindfulness person and I'm
going to say the present moment if you
can bring your attention and your full
consciousness in the present moment
that's where beauty is
this has been so wonderful Jay thank you
thank you thank you for coming on the
show yeah thank you for teaching us
about everything that you're up to yeah
this has been great thanks for having me
you're super super welcome and I would
love for everyone to get chatting more
about things like neuromodulation for
enhanced mindfulness get talking to your
friends your families your co-workers
people online on social media about what
this is what our future is like with
these technologies and give us your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode check out the links and the bio
to Jays work also check out the links in
the bio to simulation the entrepreneurs
the organizations the artists around the
world that you believe in support them
support us help us continue scaling and
impacting and growing huge shout out to
Ron Vargas for producing and directing
thank you very much and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon
you